you know I know your story but some of
the audience may not know your story
prior to you becoming who you are today
tell us a little bit about how you came
about becoming who you are today
um I'm uh an only child born in
Baltimore my parents did not graduate
from college or High School my father
worked in the post office and made maybe
ten thousand dollars a year uh when they
retired he retired at the age of 55 and
moved to a suburb of Baltimore called
West Palm Beach Florida and and uh you
know I grew up uh going up you know
Public Schools I did get a scholarship
to go to Duke University and I got a
scholarship to go to the University of
Chicago
I did serve as chairman of the board of
University of Duke University for a
while and now I'm chair of the
University Chicago Board and I have uh I
got very lucky in my business career I
started Carlisle when I was 37 it became
one of the larger private Equity firms
in the world and now I uh committed to
giving away all my money I was an
original signer of the giving pledge and
I've made large gifts to lots of
different places around the country and
I have three children they are all mbas
they're all in private Equity pursuing
what I call Mankind's highest calling
and uh they're doing okay and so I think
they're they're safely launched and they
don't need me to give them billions of
dollars to be successful David who were
you in high school if we're in 10th
Grade who were you in high school I was
a nerdy little kid uh if you asked my
high school class who would be the most
successful person in class most people
wouldn't know I was in the class I was a
large public high school 1 500 people in
my class in your class in a class so it
was big we had one guidance counselor
for 1 500 people
um it was I would say uh you know big
public high school Melting Pot public
high school but I was I skipped a year
of junior high school so I was only you
know 16 when I graduated high school I
was only 14 when I entered it so I was
you know probably young my voice
probably hadn't changed very much and
and um you know I was not a great
athlete I wasn't a great scholar I
wasn't a great anything so uh the same
was true in law school and and in
college I wasn't great at anything I got
lucky later in life you know I
determined in in parts of life uh you
divide life into thirds the first third
you often find the people are the
superstars the Rhodes Scholars the
Supreme Court clerks the people that are
the student body presidents sometimes
they make it later on in life but mostly
they don't and then people in the second
third and third third they're the ones
who kept working hard like the tortoise
versus the hair and they kind of passed
everybody else so think about your high
school class who was a superstar in that
class the person you said might be
president United States he or she may
not be that famous now all the people
who became presidents of the United
States in the last 100 years only one of
them was probably seen as a good student
or a star at that time that was probably
Bill Clinton he was a pretty good
student that was a later became a Rhodes
scholar most of the people who become
president United States are not people
that were that famous or that well known
our current president very nice person I
know him quite well but you know he was
a you know a football player in high
school not considered to be like the
president United States his predecessor
Donald Trump probably wasn't thought to
be potential president United States
when he was younger and so on so it's
just the life life evolves that way and
you can't tell who's going to be coming
the next president United States just by
looking at their resumes when they were
in high school
um you know I don't know your background
that well but were you a superstar in
high school now you're very well known
Russian that I had a 1.8 GPA literally I
had a one point I failed biology and I
was good in math that was it all right
so now you're very well known you're
prominent so forth
um in your high school class who would
have predicted that you would become
this successful zero right I went to the
Army right after high school well look I
didn't go in the army I my father was in
Marines I didn't go when I was too
skinny I didn't think I'd pass the uh
the physical
nice father was the devil dog wait were
you a superstar in high school I was not
2.2 GPA so go over your commonality 1.8
2.2 GPA no college degree
you guys are 4.0 between the two of you
that's correct I love your Edition all
right Marine Corps math there you go so
so David so you have three kids but you
were the only child so and then your
kids went to private Equity but your dad
was in the you know Postal Service and
your mom was a homemaker so what was the
advantages of being a single child was
was a disadvantages to make you want to
have three kids because you didn't have
only one kid when you were an only child
at times you might say what it's like
wouldn't it be great to have a sibling
but most of my friends who have siblings
were fighting with them all the time and
now I notice that most of my friends who
have siblings probably don't spend that
much time with them as adults so there's
pluses and one it's like everything in
life I don't regret it um if you look
back and regret things that happen in
your life you'll be very miserable the
hardest thing in life to do is to be
happy that's the most elusive thing in
life achieving personal happiness and
I'm pretty happy I got lucky in life and
I'm reasonably happy with where I am now
I wish I was younger looking I wish I
didn't have all this gray hair I wish I
could lose more weight I wish I was in
Greater shape but generally I'm
reasonably happy and if you're Jewish
that's hard to do
um so I'm reasonably happy
um
um but you know I I recognize that
happiness is difficult to achieve and
many people in life go through life not
being very happy they're sad that
they're not wealthier handsomer or
whatever it is and they never Achieve
Personal happiness you have to accept
where you are and try to make the best
of it within reason you can obviously
try to do better so what all the
craziness taking place I believe future
looks bright if you believe future looks
bright get your latest Future looks
bright hat of valuetainment it says
future looks bright here future looks
bright here we got them in white we got
them in Black we got them in red or
black on black sold out these are about
to sell out if you haven't ordered one
yet we had a person in Michigan but one
then he bought three then when those
three people wore it in the office they
had to order 58 of them because people
wanted the future looks bright hat
especially during times like this
because ain't nobody's saying future
looks spread toward your future looks
bright hat click over here and to watch
the entire podcast click here take care
everybody
[Music]